when our series the world of mothers we
are looking at what motherhood means
around the globe this morning our focus
is on a community healing from tragedy
Debora patta visited a small village in
northern Kenya where a group of women
have come to live together men are not
allowed there she is in Johannesburg
South Africa where she is based Deborah
good morning tell us more good morning
in Samba which is an extremely rural
part of Kenya there is rampant poverty
and unemployment the infant mortality
rate is over 35% but in a part of the
country where women are often regarded
as second-class citizens
there is one village where women rule
it's hard enough to be a woman in some
room but without a child here you are
regarded as nothing
dianna LeConte approved her worth by
having three children including six
month old baby Tao like so many women in
African countries where there is poverty
children are your riches it can come at
a cost though the country's husband beat
her constantly no longer able to stand
it she fled here with me a band
it's better to be a mother without a man
fantastic most stress-free years a word
you hear often in a merger but what it
really means is that these women no
longer have to fear the men who hurt
them in Cebu a woman has a 95 percent
chance of being beaten by her husband
very beautiful Judy Lee lumba was 12
when she was supposed to marry a 50 year
old man yes 20 father he was meeting me
again so that way I came again here and
I say I decided now I cannot go back
again now three months pregnant
Judy already has two daughters her dream
is that they will get education
she was denied as a child bride a mojo
has set up its own school
curiously for an all-women community
there are a lot of children around it's
a good life because as we believe if you
don't have child you are not a women
it's allowed that young ladies like me
to go and find your boyfriend outside
but you cannot bring the village so the
boyfriends Thursday yes and you can fall
pregnant if I want to get a bit me I can
work to get so it is the women who make
all the decisions here they build their
own homes with woven twigs four walls
dried kal manure for the roof and sell
beautiful handmade beadwork the money
earned shared equally what's left is put
away for emergencies when Lucille our
poorest two-year-old son fell ill with
malaria that emergency fund meant she
could take him to a clinic combine
life-saving medicine but a merger
provides so much more than financial
stability so there to help these young
women into young mothers yeah it's okay
because one mother can come and show you
how to best fit they come and show you
what you you have to eat Lucy
grew up in a merger her mother was a
founding member she got pregnant with a
man outside the village but chose to
live here she wants her son Jeremy to
break the cycle of bad symbaloo men I
just encouraged him to be a good man
dance with your wife don't give her any
stress the women of the module don't
have a lot but they have each other
and that's enough to make sure no child
goes hungry and growing up they never
experience the torment their mothers
went through it's very common across
Africa for communities to help raise
each other's children in a more Joe
there could be anything between 50 to
100 children living there now we all
know it takes a village well let me tell
you this village is thriving as women
turned the idea of community on its head
by challenging traditional beliefs Nora
absolutely fascinating Debora patta in
South Africa thank you and you've never
met a mother who isn't strong ratably
it's absolutely true and I love to the
message they want to send to their boys
because that's where you have to teach
them at a very early age how young boys
can treat women I don't think I would
like living in a place where there are
no men because as stressful as they can
be they can also give you great joy but
there is a way you know figure it out
and how they work together in harmony I
didn't have that emergency fund right
there Vijay the evident way of living